what was it like stepping into this
universe you've done very big movies
before how was Marvel different for you
this was unique you know more they know
how to do it Kevin Feige and Louis
Esposito and that hold Team Alpha top I
don't know they figured something out
then they got the great tyke of ytt in
this brilliant director so let's talk
music though for a second you're a
musician there is amazing music in this
film your character seems to play some
music talk about that tyka said yeah
let's set you up with a piano and they
cut just as we were doing it they kind
of production designed it so it seemed
outer Spacey and Sumerian and he was
playing music constantly on the scent to
keep things spirited and in his comic
and musical vein
what would you say grandmasters favorite
song is well Grandmaster I'm sure had
something we and we just lived 14
billion years you know along with his
brother Benicio del Toro a collector I
cannot wait to see that Terry fun yeah
so I'm sure his musical tastes have
through the millennia have you know had
changed currently I must like that thing
that I theme that I score to the
introduction to my character I want to
get a closer look at this I don't know
how he came about that maybe he he got
you know old DVDs maybe he borrowed a
DVD from his brothers collection
you've just written the first moments of
a collector and grandmaster that's a
great road trip yes they're excellent
adventure
[Music]